The Joe Rogan experience.
Do you have anything in this book about the Omex?
No,
not really.
Um,
I,
I mentioned,
I mentioned them briefly.
I explored the old Mac mystery,
uh,
in considerable depth.
Could you explain that to people that maybe in the fingerprints of the gods?
Yes.
So it's considered to be the earliest high culture of Central America.
Everybody's heard about the Aztecs,
everybody's heard about the Maya.
But before the Aztecs and before the Maya,
there were a culture who are referred to as the old Mex.
Again,
we don't know what they called themselves.
That's what the Aztecs called them.
They called them the old Mexican.
It means the rubber people because they see a rubber producing area of,
uh,
of Mexico.
They worked in a giant megalithic constructions that what they're most famous
for is these huge carved human heads,
which can be on a scale of up to 20 to 25 tons in weight,
uh,
and,
and which have curious features which have been interpreted variously as
Polynesian African don't look like classic,
uh,
native American features.
But one of the things,
one of the things I've realized is that there is no classic native American
feature that that Nate native Americans are a very,
have a very complex genetic story with very many different elements,
uh,
brought into it and we shouldn't be necessarily surprised by the supposedly non
native American look of these Ahmed.
What do we think those helmets were that they were wearing?
Nobody knows because no physical example of such a helmet has ever been found.
Just like no physical example of an Egyptian Pharaohs Helm,
a crown has it has ever been found.
All we see is the stone,
the stone reproductions of them do.
They're universally wear these helmets in the sale.
They,
they pretty much all wear these helmets in,
in,
in the ohmic stonework.
There's another fascinating figure from La Venta one,
one of the Omex sites,
which is the earliest ever image of a plumed or feathered serpent.
The feathered serpent is a famous icon in Central America.
Quotes,
I'll collateral who's the god of peace,
the bringer of civilization,
who is associated,
for example,
with the famous pyramid of,
of cuckold con,
which is just another name for quotes,
all collateral at Chichen eatsa where on the spring equinox or a shadow effect
creates the image of a serpent coiling down the stairway and joining with the
carved head of the serpent or the bears,
the image from La Venta.
That's the earliest image of a plumed serpent,
uh,
in the Americans.
And sitting in the middle of it.
And I made a big deal out of this cause I think it is a big deal in magicians of
the gods sitting in the middle of it is this human figure who's holding this
strange bag in his hand.
And it's just a fact that those identical bags are found in ancient Sumeria,
in the hands of individuals who were considered to be civilization bringers.
And they also show up on pillar 43 at Gabelli tappy,
uh,
I call the man bags.
Uh,
and in that case that go back to Tempe,
we know they're at least 11,000,
600 years old.
So I wonder if we're looking at a sort of badge of office of a group of
civilizes who traveled around the world trying to bring back to life at loss.
When I interrupted you talk about quartz or quad or what were you about to say?
I can't remember.
I'm in California.
I had been smoking dope.
You know,
we were talking about different things in the Amazon.
Should we rewind and figure out what we said,
the serpent guy you were talking about before?
Quite so quantum before that.
Um,
I have another question.
The omex did you,
you were talking about the genetics of these,
um,
uh,
people that live in native Americans that they vary widely,
but the Omex seemed to have very similar features,
the thick lips and noses.
Why do we think that is?
Well,
this is part of,
uh,
a curious mystery that is not unconnected to the genetic mystery.
Uh,
it's been known by archeologists for quite a long time,
that there are anomalous skulls,
uh,
in parts of Brazil,
which appear to show a very strongly Polynesian or African features,
very much like the features that we see on the,
on the old mech heads.
And a number of archeologists who got into trouble with their colleagues for
this have used that to argue many years ago,
30,
40 years ago,
that,
that the settlement story of the Americas is much more complicated than we've,
you know,
than we,
than we've realized.
And,
and what the,
what the DNA is doing is it's telling us that there was something really weird
happened,
happened with settlement.
They see what happened with those,
um,
African or Polynesian looking skulls was that they were tested for Dna,
uh,
when DNA technology was not as advanced as it is today.
And what that DNA showed was that they were more closely related to modern
native Americans than they are to any other people in the world.
So the notion that there was some connection with Polynesia or Africa was
dismissed,
but now that we have very firm evidence of an Austria lazy and genetic signal,
Aussie Australian aborigines,
Papua New Guinea Melanesians with those kinds of features now that we had the
genetic evidence that that is found in the Amazon,
we have to go back to that old evidence and and reconsider it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I would love to find out what that is.
They've always fascinated me.
The OMEX,
it's always been such a strange image.
The the large heads with helmets on them.
And how do they universally look like that?
I mean all the,
all of the features are very,
very similar.
Very,
very similar always and almost always I won't,
I won't claim that every single on that cared has a helmet on it.
Cause I think I've seen one that didn't,
there's quite a while ago since I explored the,
the Olympic area.
But what's fascinating about them is they are,
they are supposedly the first high civilization of Central America that they
create structures on the massive scale that you can see connections between
them.
And the later,
the later Maya,
that whole mystery of the Mayan calendar was clearly inherited from the Omex.
It wasn't something that Maya made up.
The old mex used that same symbolism.
So the Mayan calendar is actually an all Mac calendar,
and if we then consider the possibility that that all makes,
may just be the latest that the earliest surviving manifestation of that
calendar,
it could go back much further than that.
Yeah.